o primeiro é quero me apresentar eu sou
especialista em ajudar as pessoas a
ampliar as habilidades delas e
neutralizar os padrões sabotadores para
que elas consigam conquistar as metas
delas enquanto são felizes em todas as
áreas de suas vidas
para isso a gente precisa entender
dominar nossos pensamentos e emoções e
comportamentos para que a gente consiga
conquistar tudo que a gente quer e viver
diariamente da maneira que a gente quer
e o que eu vim aqui deixar com vocês
hoje é ampliar como todos esses as
pessoas incríveis tiveram aqui ampliar
as possibilidades que vocês vêem nas
vidas de vocês
e também deixar mais poder de
intervenção na própria vida de vocês nas
suas mãos
beleza e eu quero começar fazendo uma
pergunta eu quero que vocês se lembrem
se vocês já pararam para pensar que o
tempo inteiro a gente está tentando
consertar alguma coisa ou se consertar o
fazer alguma coisa melhor ter um
relacionamento melhor do que a gente
teve antes ter mais dinheiro do que a
gente tinha conseguido pra pagar alguma
coisa emagrecer o peso que ganhou
programar melhor o segundo semestre
melhor que o primeiro e por aí vai
são várias variações disso o tempo
inteiro ea gente está nessa rodinha
derrames treinar e muitas vezes esse
padrão de busca em 2019 é tão forte que
a gente nem sente que a gente está nesse
modo de consertar mas quando foi que
tudo começou
isso tudo começou muito muito antes de a
gente ter as redes sociais para se
comparar isso começou lá atrás quando a
gente era muito novinho ea gente podia
simplesmente pintar qualquer coisa fora
da linha dormir onde tivesse sono querer
fazer as necessidades onde dava vontade
a gente tinha essa liberdade ou até um
pouco mais velho quando a gente podia
falar que queria ser bombeiro professor
astronauta jogador de futebol
cantor atriz e tudo bem aquilo ali
parecia que eram possibilidades reais na
nossa vida
ninguém falou pra gente você precisa ser
realista não é assim
que acontece em sua vida não aquilo ali
era real pra gente e até quando durou
essa liberdade toda mão durou até o dia
que nossa mãe nosso pai ou qualquer
outro lado chegou pra gente falou assim
não é assim
não é assim que acontece se você fizer
isso não vai dar certo se você fizer
brincar dessa forma seus amiguinhos vão
gostar de você
se você fizer isso você não vai ganhar
presente de natal
se você não assistiu à direita e não vai
passar de ano e aí começou essa é a
esses padrões começaram a surgir né ii e
o que a gente começou a entender desde
muito cedo
desde muito cedo a gente entendeu que se
eu fizer errado eu sofro
se eu fizer o que essas pessoas estão
chamando de certo eu não só vou fazer o
certo como eu também vou ter a aprovação
das pessoas e se eu fizer errado como a
gente já percebeu se eu sofro
foi daí exatamente dessa época bem
antiga que começou o famoso medo de
falhar
só que se a gente busca essas
referências
pra ter certeza que a gente está agindo
certo ou no nosso passado ou comparando
com alguma pessoa para entender se eu
estou seguindo no caminho certo
a gente até consegue entender que a
gente está naquele caminho supostamente
certo mas a gente perde totalmente a
nossa liberdade e desde sempre o ser
humano age assim porque porque desde
sempre o ser humano ele está em busca de
amor desde 100
é assim que a gente foi programado nós
somos o único ser vivo que está
programado para precisar de amor e desde
que a gente nasceu se a gente não tiver
amor
nós somos o único ser vivo que vai
morrer então está programado na gente no
cérebro e bioquimicamente e todas as
confusões mentais que vão surgir na
nossa vida de alguma forma elas
acontecem por a gente receber ou não
amor
e aí quando a gente vai começando o
texto esse monte de regras e padrões
se a gente começar a viver sem entender
a maneira que a gente é programado sem a
gente entender como que surgiram todas
as regras
a gente vai acumular padrões
que muitas das vezes eles estão
totalmente desatualizados padrão de
vidas e pra gente conseguir essa certeza
de que eu tô certo eu consigo confirmar
que a gente está seguindo como a gente
falou eu vou buscar o meu passado eu vou
buscar na comparação
só que se eu tomar aquela rodinha de
hamster sempre tentando tá em cima do
famoso trilho aquele ditado tem que
voltar pra cima do trilho né seguir o
certo eu vou estar sempre atrasado eu
vou estar sempre com aquela sensação de
busca de alguma coisa com a sensação de
que eu tenho que entender seu tom certo
tem que consertar aquilo que eu não fiz
tão certo
ou realmente deu certo mais perfeição né
eu poderia ter feito um pouco melhor
então se a gente está sempre atrasado
a gente tem essa sensação de que está
sempre atrasado qual o problema real
disso porque como a gente sabe que de
alguma forma a gente não pode voltar no
passado para mudar alguma coisa a gente
sem recursos
a gente se sente de mãos atadas
então automaticamente dá aquela sensação
de eu não tenho que fazer aqui ea gente
vai perdendo energia
então por isso que o atraso ele é igual
a desmotivação e porque é que o atraso
ele causa isso tudo um momento que a
gente vai sair desse atraso o momento
que a gente vai sair dessa questão de se
consertar
ele é diferente para cada pessoa eo
quanto ele vai acontecer quando a gente
entender de verdade de verdade que não
precisa ser consertado o meu momento foi
quando eu estava acabando um curso
ele foi na verdade o segundo curso que
eu fiz de alta performance e eu estava
lá na califórnia aprendendo sobre
desenvolvimento humano e tudo isso e
quando acabar o curso no domingo me deu
aquela aquela aquela vontade de
descansar de curtir o que tinha acabado
de acontecer e aí eu senti que eu tinha
que passear eu estava sozinho lá na
califórnia
e aí eu fui pra uma praça em san diego
nessa praça
tinha um chafariz e tinha também uma
marina o pôr do sol estava ali baixando
uma imagem super bacana e eu estava ali
agradecendo poxa oportunidade legal sabe
está aqui na califórnia aprendendo epi
levando isso para as pessoas e e
ajudando nos processos delas e vai ser
incrível quando chegar no brasil e tal
e de repente isso me deu uma profunda
gratidão
eu não sabia exatamente por que mas eu
comecei a me emocionar naquela hora e eu
fiquei tentando entender e quando eu
comecei como a ck minhas lágrimas eu
comecei a me dar conta de que aquela
oportunidade ele está lá estudando é
fora do brasil e aprendendo coisas que
muitas vezes demora um tempo né pra
chegar às vezes aqui pra gente eu senti
que aquilo tudo ali dependia de que
algumas coisas tivessem acontecido para
que eu tivesse chegado ali e foi nesse
dia que eu estava exatamente nesse lugar
nesse pôr do sol olhando pra isso
sentindo esse cheirinho de de fim de
tarde de grama molhada
foi quando realmente me dei conta de que
tudo o que me fazia me senti atrasada
tudo o que fazia querer consertar a
minha vida e fazer diferente foi
exatamente o que tinha me levado até ali
naquele momento
foi ali que eu me dei conta de que tudo
estava acontecendo exatamente como tinha
que acontecer e até os momentos que
tinham sido aparentemente errados na
verdade nunca tinham dado errado e eu me
dei conta de que todas as outras coisas
boas que eu tinha na minha vida
também aconteceram porque eu estava
vivendo tudo exatamente do jeito que foi
tudo aconteceu de bom nas nossas vidas
porque nem tudo aconteceu do jeito que a
gente quis e todos os dias difíceis
todas as dúvidas todos os estresses
todas as distrações tudo o que aconteceu
aconteceu porque tinha que acontecer e
te trouxe o que você ama a sua vida
e eu duvido muito que a gente queira
fazer essa troca até consertar nossa
vida entregar em troca tudo que a gente
mais uma pra consertar
então ao invés de querer fazer algo pra
conseguir apagar o meu passado para
conseguir consertar isso tudo me fez me
dá conta de que na verdade nunca deu
errado eu estava no lugar certo o tempo
inteiro e tudo que tinham dado errado
inclusive de quase chegado a 100 quilos
de tanto peso que carregava em mim ter
ficado doente ter tido vários estresses
que eu nunca soube porque tinha
acontecido desde lá atrás da minha
infância quando tudo começou a ser
programado
essas situações essas experiências foram
necessárias para que eu tivesse aqui
para que eu tivesse descoberto a minha
missão de vida para que eu tivesse saído
de uma carreira e pudesse ter entrado na
outra e e pudesse inclusive ter
descoberto que a minha grande paixão e
poder contribuir com as pessoas
entendendo de onde elas vêm entendendo
que a vida delas não precisa ser
perfeita porque eu não sabia disso
eu me sentia inadequada eu me sentia
desmerecedora eu me sentia totalmente
tendo que consertar alguma coisa mas eu
quero deixar com vocês que a gente
sempre está no lugar certo na hora certa
exatamente onde a gente está a gente
teve nesse lugar onde imagina se a gente
ia querer trocar o que a gente mais ama
por ter consertado algo que veio de um
padrão que pode ter começado quando eu
nasci e veio de uma pessoa que eu posso
nem mais ter contato com ela na minha
vida então eu quero convidar vocês agora
para que vocês consigam ter essas provas
com vocês não só porque estou falando
que vocês consigam dessa prova de que
vocês têm esse poder de intervenção eu
vou chamar vocês fazem exercício bem
rápido
beleza quero que vocês pegam os dois
dedos por favor
indicadores assim e façam como se fosse
um gancho bem simples
e aí vocês vão falar o nome de vocês e
vamos fazer
pra abrir então por exemplo cuidado para
não bater na medida em que lado vocês
vão falar eu sou gabriela eu sou
gabriela eu sou gabriel é o nome de
vocês falem alto até abrir por favor faz
força até abrir isso algumas pessoas
estão abrindo faz força e mesmo pra
abrir beleza
ok virão mais ou menos o tamanho da
força de vocês precisarão agora vão
fazer exatamente a mesma coisa com outro
nome qualquer nome de preferência um
nome completamente diferente de vocês
então por exemplo eu sou o pedro eu sou
pedro eu sou pedro e vai mandar abrir
fala o nome diferente
beleza
alguém aqui percebeu que a força da
segunda foi muito menor do que na
primeira
beleza e por que isso aconteceu porque
era mentira
o nosso corpo ele reconhece a verdade e
rejeita a mentira ele mostra isso pra
gente
então toda vez que você se sentir sem
força
talvez a gente esteja buscando algo que
não sejam os nossos padrões seja uma
comparação com outra pessoa ou até no
passado bastante antigo
quando a gente busca certeza e aprovação
em alguma coisa que não é nosso e eu sei
que isso pode parecer clichê mas ao
mesmo tempo muitas vezes a gente não
bucha porque a gente entrou no
automático
né agora imagina essa força essa
diferença de força no seu dia a dia na
sua conquista de metas se você pudesse
ter a maior força sempre será que é
melhor então querer consertar o passado
com essa base em comparação né ou em
alguma definição que de repente veio de
alguém até com boa intenção mas de
repente não é você faz a gente querer
apagar tudo o que vai trazer a nossa
força e faz a gente queria pagar
inclusive os nossos êxitos e outra forma
aumentar os recursos para você entender
a força que você tem de intervenção na
sua realidade e na sua própria vida é
fazendo um tipo de comparação que eu
quero compartilhar com vocês
pensa então agora vamos fazer um outro
exercício juntos quem você admira uma
pessoa um conhecido a um amigo um cantor
uma atriz um atleta o empresário enfim
essa pessoa que você admira qualquer
pessoa
vamos pensar numa pessoa juntos que todo
mundo conhece por exemplo o ao disney
onde nenhuma pessoa que muito
provavelmente assim como a pessoa que
você escolheu não teve a vida perfeita
mas ele se superou constantemente e é
admirado até 50 anos depois da morte
dele pela sua perseverança pelos seus
filmes pelos seus parques e tudo mas ele
faliu mas ele dormiu na rua a vida dele
não foi perfeito
outras pessoas como atletas que a gente
sabe que também não tem a vida perfeita
caem levantam perdem e ganham treinam às
vezes quatro anos até ter alguma outra
chance de atingir seu objetivo e a gente
admira não porque eles nunca perderam
mas porque também eles têm perseverança
resistência na resiliência outro tipo de
pessoa atores um ator como o robert
downey junior o homem de ferro
ele também é um cara que está longe de
ter vida perfeita muitas pessoas sabem
que ele até foi preso
mas hoje ele é um dos atores mais
admirados e mais bem pagos do cinema
inclusive de toda a história a vida
desses caras é totalmente imperfeita né
a vida desses caras é exatamente igual à
sua
você já é quem você admira você é o tipo
de pessoa que essas pessoas são talvez a
sua história de vida seja um pouco
diferente mas você se você busca esse
tipo de pessoa que supera que cai abrir
mão de querer ser perfeito você não
gosta disso parece querer consertar sua
vida você não gosta quando não têm
quedas
assange e se você já é quem você admira
se essa já é a sua identidade porque
agora você não pode se admirar maggi
então agora é a hora de se comparar do
jeito certo
com quem você admira imagina que louco
você chegar num lugar e as pessoas virem
com aquele discurso de que nossa
comparação é tudo de ruim no mundo as
pessoas estão perdendo a identidade tal
você chega assim nossa
adoro comparação sensacional percebe o
tamanho da importância que o
autoconhecimento e o autorrespeito
começam a ter na vida de vocês
e na realidade de vocês pra finalizar
eu quero que você acabe com qualquer
dúvida de que você não tem o poder de
intervenção na realidade de vocês
qualquer dúvida e eu tenho certeza disso
porque o nosso cérebro ele aprende dessa
forma por repetição tudo o que você
aprendeu como certo até agora foi assim
você aprendeu que azul e azul porque
você repetiu essa informação pra você
inclusive aquelas informações do colégio
que pode ser que vocês nunca mais usem
pois é assim que vocês aprenderam e
também foi assim que vocês aprenderam
sobre a visão de vocês mesmo o nosso
cérebro a neurociência comprova vocês
podem sim mudar a realidade de vocês e
mudar a visão de vocês não importa o que
aconteceu no passado a qualquer momento
da vida de vocês e eu quero fechar esse
dia essa noite pra que vocês realmente
se liberta de qualquer limitação que
possa aparecer na frente de vocês com
uma pergunta o que ela sempre me motiva
a buscar o que eu quero na minha vida
com mais justiça com um pouco mais alto
respeito com um pouco mais de humildade
e confiança não é maravilhoso ter esse
incrível poder de criação da sua
realidade e ela começará exatamente com
você
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]